all right let's do this boys see what's
going on commander our current position
is here just outside resistance
headquarters when we're not on the move
this will serve as our home and our
source of supplies okay the councilman
is track the alien black site to this
region unfortunately we don't have its
exact coordinates yet if we're going to
have any chance of finding this facility
we'll need to make contact with the
local resistance cell nearby tigon has a
theory about how we might reach out to
them without getting the aliens
attention but we'll need to give him
time to conduct his research
whatever you say that's you alone on
that commander we have to start making
contact with other regions yeah I got it
I got a global resistance and take on
Advent come on looks like you won't have
time for that just yet though remote
reconnaissance may have found something
not far from our current position that
is it investigation finding new course
let's do it let's get over there
commander while we're waiting for new
missions or the completion of our
research we can pass time by scanning at
sites like this one on your order we'll
start our scans of the surrounding area
hey the outcome of this research can
only further our advantage
commander he sat on their research
traffic and it's a plate in our 10 alien
alloys the advent offices appear to be
similar if not physically the same it's
the common Advent trooper that discussed
that work and agility
however fueled reports indicate a more
developed mental acuity as the officers
do provide tactical directives to the
subordinate Advent for discussing
okay apparently my predecessor was
something of a brute when it came to
handling the interrogation and autopsy
[ __ ] weren't we just here okay
[Music]
okay so we got engineer so I honestly
have no idea what the [ __ ] we're doing
we must make contact [ __ ] locked
setting course for the western US
precinct
okay so we cleared this
you start work on the new facility right
away commander I'll send word when it's
up and running
there's room for us to expand our
facilities on board the Avenger
connector but we'll need more engineers
to clear up space for construction first
okay
[ __ ] hi I literally have no [ __ ] idea
what the [ __ ] I'm doing in this in this
game not again oh [ __ ] I need an talc
I figured this was easier than your last
procedure yes central commander yes I
find the process to be far less
disconcerting God has already expired
the results are its best you see here's
a chapel penis you're selling autopsy of
the Advent captain has confirmed the
existence of an implant similar in
design to the unit I extracted from the
commander but there are differences
what's the difference kind of
differences ID exact that's what I want
too now you see is being pulled directly
from this Advent captain's implant the
sequence here is essentially you
commander or at least the tactical
information they were processing through
your mind as you can see the data is
nearly identical okay
we're using you against us yes however
the advent data shows signed the decayed
removing the commander from their
network has likely caused significant
damage network network what was being
here is a psionic network these implants
are capable of receiving and
transmitting information a great deal of
information somehow included in a stream
of psionic energy my working theory as
it uses this network to augment the
tactical readiness of its troops as well
as disseminate orders from its Central
Command observe okay fellas shed
subjects diminished condition the
implant continues to have an effect it
makes it wears pants on machine
achievement nor a weakness potentially
but I need direct access to their
network to know for sure
I'm guessing that won't be easy we need
an active link and that would mean
hacking alive I'd been on sir like I
said not easy
well gadem still it's the best lead
we've got you are calling commander
stamp straight my call I'm the [ __ ]
commanded okay I've updated our latest
operational objectives commander the
Advent captain seems to provide a means
of stabilizing the link between the
local subordinate and the Advent Network
tower itself commander if we're going to
try to build this skull Jack that Titan
came up with we're going to need a
specialized facility to test it and
assumed you'd make that research a
priority commander I'll notify you as
soon as the report is available okay so
what the [ __ ] is going on here
I still can't go here we have to make
contact with local resistance so I need
to build up [ __ ] no we have allies
scattered in cities throughout the globe
who are willing to share their knowledge
of happens operations
the aliens are okay we're going to
rescue this bad shape will be up to you
to ensure the set of our operatives
commander good luck okay what about how
do I get like the enhanced armor I
thought I had [ __ ] better armor okay
just [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] that [ __ ] let's do this
[Music]
okay let's try have to [ __ ] anything up
anymore guys guy Ranger deploy in
position for deployment again Delta F
con - Delta F thom - south tau f quanto
quad 33 penis Delta penis Delta penis
Delta penis we being held by Advent
forces in this area we need to secure
the site remove any hostile standing in
our way and free the prisoner and okay
let's go HS o let's go come on trying to
Jack fine come on let's talk it takes
ten years alone come on
even they're like hey what's going on
like why is this akin to a lot the [ __ ]
is going on
she shot though okay here we go
menace 1 5 we have a confirmed location
for the VIP move to rendezvous eliminate
all hostile contacts alright where are
the enemies get the [ __ ] in there it
gives a [ __ ] yeah
ready anyways get the [ __ ] in there
let's come finish okay where the alley
we put that's right see housing I don't
you do that
can't tell let's do this the
old-fashioned way Mme
can I go and I hit that batch no good
get [ __ ] it are you gonna shoot at me
my control I carry it like a film in
yeah you stupid [ __ ] she doing she show
yes [ __ ]
okay we got eliminate this [ __ ] to the
first person
why is you going again just shoot this
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] face please now
now just pop this patch right here did
he get damaged now grenade jealous [ __ ]
that's it what the [ __ ] was that what
the [ __ ] up where's the [ __ ] okay how
how does want to open this
already there
double-time okay can I set the sky guard
there's that bench moving out
some tennis one-five be advised hostile
interceptors are inbound on your current
position firebrand there's a limited
window to provide extraction okay you're
going to [ __ ] hack this patch or what
hot doors hot there we go let's take
this [ __ ] secure we're on the move
- one five status confirmed VIP is in
tow
proceed to the extraction point tanks uh
where the [ __ ] is extraction point I see
what happens
any LA's over here holy [ __ ] so [ __ ]
[ __ ] aliens right there
okay we're going to do a little we're
going to do a little dos a Dell okay
that's we're going to do a little dose a
though if I take this guy wait did he
already get him what's going on
what the [ __ ] what's that on here and I
have a [ __ ] Kelly that estate deal
with this [ __ ] [ __ ] that chick go out
there
Oh what the [ __ ] are those enemies I
can't tell what could you do
can I
to focus that great he just got his dick
sucked
today's Venice one five we're picking up
an enemy transport inbound on your
current position okay [ __ ] we have to
[ __ ] eliminate this dude open closed
or we load throw frag grenade 59% [ __ ]
that is risky now [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's
not risky moving to designated position
let's blow this guy's dick yeah you like
that this guy can this guy this [ __ ]
rum got it
oh [ __ ] you got a dick sucked so what
happened I was [ __ ] dumb
this my guy I guess this is my guy can I
just like [ __ ] this guy's up there
living to designated coordinates okay
look yeah blow this [ __ ] shoot cut
hostile neutralized you bet your ass
with naturalised you can assure me that
[ __ ] is that all right second turkey
baster
okay come on come on
I've been troops yes stupid [ __ ] can I
escape you there now that's affirmative
okay and we just pop this [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
he's done oh this is [ __ ] stupid this
is [ __ ] stupid and I got down closed
our [ __ ] up now
[ __ ] just hunker down I'll get up
okay [ __ ] should I help this guy out
yeah I should [ __ ] it I should help this
guy out
on the move
countess bench enemies down what do we
go here Wow
now fetch the [ __ ] that where are they
at how do I get them like pick up the
[ __ ] shut up [ __ ] sorry
[ __ ] how do i zoom in now
[ __ ] zoomed out out now okay [ __ ] it
I don't know what's going on but all I
know is I'm going to get the [ __ ] out of
here
get the [ __ ] out of there
all right let's not be a little [ __ ] we
need to get you out of here
mark [ __ ] all right come on
- stop shot plays now he's going to
shoot out [ __ ] the [ __ ] you're doing
how do I [ __ ] zoom in
now these [ __ ] sent our camera and oh
it's a okay got the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
good night dispatch see that yes so far
so you can go great
oh great
oh [ __ ] people are [ __ ] savage send
an enemy I'm on the move all right
[ __ ] kill this [ __ ] 81% kill
confirmed running drawn ammo who you
directing Menace 1/5 hostile
interceptors are on high-speed approach
your window for extraction is closing
bucket cf arcing at her
oh great please don't kill our
all right [ __ ] no don't shoot got it
you're gonna get shot now
all right let's see what he does
I'm out of here Oh in the rain get the
[ __ ] out of here
hey Zack out there yeah he's gonna shoot
he's gonna shoot it definitely got a
[ __ ] yeah he's in the range please don't
die [ __ ] she got shot up security all
right get the [ __ ] out of here all right
dad wait dad I betcha as we did it thank
ya thank ya
excellent no soldiers killed all and
wounded hysterically no record okay
thank you thank you